[Music]
hi
i'm michael stevens but who are you
do you even know who you are are you
your memories
i don't remember that i don't remember
that at all are you the choices you make
the focus tester is actually a magician
that's scary or are you your past
i've hit the back of my head and
forgotten my entire life
just like you hit a delete button on a
[Music]
computer
have you ever looked at a photograph of
yourself and thought
that's what i look like we often think
we look
bad or not right in photos because
photos
show us what we really look like to
other people
the you that you're used to seeing is
mirror you every mirror you look into
reverses your face most selfie cameras
do this too
so we tend to prefer that version of
ourselves
if you want to see yourself in a mirror
the way other people see you in real
life
take two mirrors and position them at a
90 degree angle
what you see won't be yourself reversed
but
how you look in real life so who would
you say you
are really are you how you look or
how you dress or are you the atoms that
make you up
because all of those things change
throughout your life
ah maybe the real common thread that
which doesn't change
is your history your memory
but what if we remember things
differently from the way they
actually happened does that mean we
don't know
ourselves
false memories are frighteningly easy
to create today we're gonna make some
and we're gonna have a little fun doing
it
we have created a fake game show called
who you were we're gonna bring
contestants down memory lane and have
them tell us about
their past some of which we're going to
completely make up
we're going to plant a few little seeds
in this minefield and see if we can grow
some fake memories
hi i'm michael stevens and welcome to
the show that takes you on a trip
down memory lane from who you are
all the way back through who you
were please welcome today's very special
guest
timothy de la ghetto thanks for coming
in
thanks for having me excited to kind of
dive into some memories yeah i don't
really know what to expect to begin
though let's give the audience a taste
of your life oh my god let's take a look
so tim was raised in california where he
and his parents owned and operated a
thai food restaurant
tim found popularity as a rapper
comedian actor and internet personality
and has attracted over
3 million subscribers in order to kind
of
see how you became who you are today
let's go back
to who you were let's do it we spoke to
your parents
and they told us some of their favorite
memories from when you were very very
young okay
i'm going to start with some true
stories before i slip
in the false memory when you were seven
you were pretty much held prisoner by a
very controlling schoolgirl
the girl took control of your life and
always wanted to know what you were
doing i remember her
like she was like my best friend sort of
but then she was also very like
possessive of me but you guys
aren't together still no we might be
facebook friends okay
here's a memory you weren't a crybaby on
the first day of school yeah
until you noticed that all the other
kids were crying and then you joined in
you know i empathize with people right
and uh i was just kind of like
helping them feel like we were all a
team now here's the fake story
we made up out of thin air here's
another memory
when you were about four or five years
old okay you actually took a ride in a
hot air balloon
but you dropped something from the
balloon
i don't remember that at all really like
at all i'm going deep
yeah no clue timothy is not accepting
the story as
truth yet time for our second subject
dylan how are you i'm doing great man
you were uh inseparable from your
superman cape when you were young once
you even tried to use your superpowers
to stop a car driving down the street
yeah try to stop a car like with my with
my hand did you succeed
you know the dude hit his brakes okay
next memory so when you're about four or
five years old
you took a ride in a hot air balloon and
you dropped something
huh uh
i'm not sure if i remember that to be
honest sometimes enriching the false
story with a realistic detail
can trigger the brain to begin filling
in the memory
here goes did you have a favorite toy or
anything that maybe
you had brought oh i mean i had like
some action figures i think
um i do remember like losing one i'm not
sure like that was like the
what happened if i was in a hot air
balloon
that's a crazy adventure if i actually
did something like that
hi victoria when you were around four or
five years old
you took a ride in a hot air balloon and
you dropped something
i don't remember that four or five years
old
up in the air no how many times you've
been in a hot air balloon
none of course none of the subjects
remember the balloon ride
it never happened but we aren't done
with them yet
24 hours from now we'll take our
subjects
to echo park okay the site of their
supposed childhood balloon ride to see
if any of the seeds i planted today
have taken root this is where you took
your first hot air balloon ride
are you serious i'm serious
we might not be able to remember our
past accurately all the time
but at least we have direct insight into
our own mental states
we know how we feel what we like and why
except we don't psychologists call our
tendency to overvalue
how we explain our own behavior while
distrusting that other people truly
understand their own
the introspection illusion an
interesting manifestation of this bias
is something called choice blindness
it is surprisingly easy to fool someone
into believing they made a choice that
they never did
and the amazing thing is that they'll
also defend
that fake choice as if it were what they
had always wanted
we feel like we know ourselves pretty
well we know why we like the things we
like
we know why we decided to do the things
that we did
but do we
today we'll be showing our subjects sets
of
photos and asking them to choose the
photo of the person they'd prefer to
work with
but this isn't exactly what it looks
like the
focus tester is actually a magician
who will be using sleight of hand to
swap some of the faces
they choose for faces they've rejected
will they catch the trick or will they
justify and explain a decision
they never actually made thank you for
participating in this study of first
impressions in the workplace
you will be shown sets of faces and be
asked to select which person you would
prefer to work with are you ready to
begin i am yes
cool so would you rather work with
person a
or person b person b
that's as complex as it gets person a or
person b
a b b
a b a so we've made a pile of your ideal
workplace colleagues
effectively uh now part two is
to if you could fill out the women in
the workplace segment of the
questionnaire
all of this business about filling out a
survey it's just to distract them from
what's about to happen
because our magician is going to make a
swap
there it is two of the eight photos have
been swapped out for pictures our
subject rejected
what will she say when presented with
photos of people she didn't
actually choose now on their own merits
i want to ask you
what it was about them that made you
pick them okay we'll start with a
picture that she did pick
before we slip in the rejects so why did
you want to work with this person
she looks nice she looks really nice but
i think the person i compared her to
didn't look very friendly gotcha here's
another pair of photos where she had a
clear preference
person b now
we're going to show her the picture she
actually rejected
why did you want to work with this
person um
she just looked nicer than the other one
yeah that was one where the other girl
didn't look very nice at all
is she just misremembering this one
choice
how about another photo she rejected uh
why did you prefer to work with this
person
she looks super sweet so that was what
you were thinking when you chose that
jose i feel like she'd be one of those
girls that would like on the birthdays
get you the card and
she just looks really sweet this isn't
just simple misremembering
this is fabricating a past that never
happened
will any of our other subjects justify
choices they
never made person a or person b
hey now we'll present him with a photo
he rejected so why did you choose to
work with this person
she gave off the appearance of
a genuine person who would be easy to
work with
people are completely fabricating
justifications for things they never
even did i think
we could actually up the annie we've
been swapping two
of the eight faces now we'll swap four
let's see if she justifies the photos
that she actually
rejected i liked her her look
i like to work with confident people so
to me she looked like a confident person
as a woman i want to like help other
women grow and succeed and give them
advice
and i gravitated towards that picture
because of that reason
she looked like a type of person you
could invite in and ask
advice and learn from her experiences
so i think she had that type of look
she looks like she might be like a wise
type of person
she looks confident so i think that's
why i picked her
she seems so sure of her decisions but
let's give her one last look
in particular i'm curious about how you
feel about these four
you know there's the confidence and um
kindness
and somebody young i feel like that
would be people i could work with
so i i stand by my decision cool yes
perfect the interesting thing about this
study okay
is they are not actually the ones you
chose no
these ones were they were switched while
you were filling in the questionnaire
it's this phenomenon what's known as
choice blindness if we think we made a
choice we will find a way to justify
that choice
even if we don't know that's what we
made okay i was trying to justify these
four
because i forgot that i picked those
four it's like a debate like no matter
what what side i was on i was gonna give
reasons for that
i'm not happy that i did that but um
that's the reason why
you pulled this complete switcheroo on
me and i wasn't even like conscious
about it that's scary
you may think you know why you do the
things you do
but in a pinch your mind can replace the
truth
the actual past with completely new
explanations
that you will confidently believe to be
exactly what happened
but what if fabricating the past
is all you can do that may be the case
for someone with extreme
dissociative amnesia when you can't
remember your life at all what happens
to your sense of self
so scott you have retrograde
amnesia correct tell me what that is
how it happened i walked into a restroom
at my office building
and i slipped on an oily substance
and hit the back of my head and suffered
you know it was like four or five inch
laceration
and that gave me retrograde amnesia
which means
everything autobiographical and
historical
in my life were completely erased erased
just like you hit a delete button on a
computer i forgot my entire life
i had no idea who my wife was her name
my children it was absolutely
horrifying wow and this happened eight
years ago
what memories did you have you still
knew
english you still knew things like how
to ride a bike
that's a totally different kind of
memory right when i handed him a
toothbrush he didn't
comb his hair with it he put it in his
mouth but he didn't know what it was
called
and you didn't remember ever using one
before but
you didn't have autobiographical
memories that involved toothbrushes but
you
knew how to operate it because that's a
procedural memory
wow exactly things like that you know
are stored in a different part
of the brain so it was almost like
you were you were born into this
person's body didn't get to choose you
have a name you have a wife you have a
house you have a past
and you have to just accept that all of
those are what you've been dealt
right that's exactly how i felt like i
stepped into somebody else's life and
a lot of it i didn't believe i just
couldn't picture that
you know i flew airplanes or was in the
nfl
it just seemed like nothing i would ever
do
and a lot of it you know she had to
prove to me
she put together a whole album full of
pictures
she kind of put my life in a
chronological order
and that kind of you know filled some of
the gaps of
who i was and i've heard that
you know you are who you are from the
things you've experienced in your
memories
and when i hear that it's like a knife
in my heart
because it's like then who am i so scott
when you're asked
who are you what do you say it's hard to
answer that question because i haven't
figured out
who i am i'm developing every day
my personality and who i am
but inside of my brain i don't know who
i am
you are the collection of all of your
memories right i mean that's
your story those are things that
happened to you and they're in the past
they can't be changed
but it can be created
an illuminating harvard study found
numerous examples of
seemingly sane people who believed that
they had recovered memories of past
lives and alien abductions and there's
no deceit
these people actually believe that these
events occurred
and i remember i was just literally
scared to death
once people have decided that a memory
is real
the brain can fill in details that never
happened
especially if the clues you're getting
or what people are telling you
isn't entirely accurate leading
cognitive psychologist elizabeth loftus
made that point in a 1996 experiment
where she convinced over 25 of the
subjects that they had been lost in a
shopping mall
as a child your brain will just take
those untruths and run with them and
fill in details out of nowhere
completely changing your personal
history
when we last saw our who you were
subjects they did not recall the false
memory we planted
when you were about four or five years
old you actually took a ride in a hot
air balloon but you dropped something
i'm not sure if i remember that
to be honest you took a ride in a hot
air balloon and you dropped something
i don't remember that we've let the
memory sink in
overnight and today we're going to see
if physical stimuli will help solidify
this story in their minds
today is all about you and a little
drive down your memory lane
this is where you rode over
in a hot air balloon in a hot air
balloon
that's right maybe my parents mistake me
for like a
another kid some other kids we'll get
out
and walk around and see what can come
back
let it all soak in and tell me
if anything's coming back to you hmm
i don't know man snot's not popping up
you dropped
something when you were in this hot air
balloon
will this be the detail that pushes tim
to remember
the event what could i have dropped what
did i walk around with back then
i spent another 15 minutes attempting to
kick start tim's brain with details of
the false balloon story
has anything come back
no
[Laughter]
tim's brain doesn't seem susceptible to
the false memory
let's check in with the other subjects
this is where you took your hot air
balloon ride
really yeah
this is echo park yeah and it was about
15 years ago yeah you don't remember any
anything from this no of course he
doesn't
it never happened this
is where you took your first hot air
balloon ride this is this is it
yeah are you serious i'm serious
does this bring back memories um
you don't remember anything from this um
i do remember like something as a kid i
i dropped something he dropped something
now how do you suppose he got that idea
he dropped something
dylan's mind is gradually taking an idea
we planted
and adopting it as his own memory detail
i could have been around here riding my
bike then we took the hot air balloon
ride
and possibly dropped a superman cape
for some people physical sensations can
be an effective trigger to bring back
real or imaginary memories
what about smells and sounds
well when i was four or five and i was
here i remember it smelling
fresh this sensory memory may be a
jumping off point to begin accepting
the false memory remember looking down
on the park
from above i might remember um
being able to overlook the water
um
i remember like standing over and
squatting
and like just being so
[Music]
happy to be up there and the wind
blowing
my hair back and my dad kept telling me
to sit down and i wouldn't sit down
yeah you weren't scared how high up were
you
probably like
800 feet no kidding yeah wow
victoria's false memory is beginning to
take hold
with the help of her imaginative
subconscious brain
what do you remember seeing from up in
the hot air balloon
the water fountain for sure yeah and i
could have been crazy but i think that i
could have felt like almost a little bit
of mist hit my skin
from the water fountain what color was
the balloon
i want to say it was red red yeah
let's see if the seed i planted earlier
has taken hold
you took a ride in a hot air balloon and
you dropped something
i don't remember that you dropped
something
i did at that age i was a huge barney
fan
i just like remember just like looking
down and him just being gone
about where did it fall do you think um
i would say six or seven blocks
away oh really so not in the water no
by now it seems victoria's brain has
turned our suggested memory
into a complete childhood experience
i remember waking up at like
nine in the morning getting in the car
and then my mom and i being in the car
having no idea where we were going
because he loved to do that
just put the family in the car and just
go somewhere and just like surprise us
victoria is personalizing this false
memory
by merging it with pleasant details from
her childhood
and next thing you know like we're just
like flying over like the whole like
greater los
angeles area so who do you think was in
the
basket with you well definitely both my
parents
i know we got something to eat
afterwards i almost want to say like a
churro or something like that
post balloon churro yeah it's a classic
now that our subjects are convinced that
the balloon ride
happened it's time for a reality check
tell your mom uh the memory we went on
like a hot air balloon ride
and i dropped i think my superman cape
why are you looking like that
no dylan that never happened
that never happened wait what there was
never
a balloon ride we made the whole story
up well
you made most of it up oh wow
but isn't that amazing because remember
we
planted that story no that is that's
actually really crazy i
was actually having like these these
like weird faint memories of me like
looking over like the pond and like you
know i don't even know has dylan been to
echo park before
oh wow and now it's victoria's turn for
a rude awakening from her father
hi story's not true
what you've never been in a hot air
balloon what are you guys
talking about why would you make that up
did you truly believe that you'd been in
a hot air balloon yes
you remembered so many details yes of
something that
never happened yes how many times you've
been in a hot air balloon
none so what were you remembering
i'm not entirely sure because i really
do
feel like i have a memory we all
are susceptible to this i really felt
like i had
experienced that experience and what
about our youtuber
tim well tim i'll tell you what it's not
surprising that you don't remember
anything from
it because it never happened i knew it
that's why i do tim wasn't susceptible
but false memories are
common and can have real world
implications
the innocence project of the united
states claims that faulty eyewitness
memories
account for 72 percent of convictions
overturned by dna evidence
so who are you well how could you be
any one thing you are always changing if
you can lose track of your past
and your memories can be altered or
implanted
in the end who are you really maybe
you're the stories you're telling
yourself
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
my
you